without example i would say
like i don't know from the
stuff i've heard from like new couples
um before they move in together into
their new home is before you move in you
have a discussion and negotiate the
house household things
certain rules boundaries things like
that so that you avoid that sort of
thing
she was just staying with me oh okay i
thought that's what i'm trying to say
like okay
okay if she was moving in i think it
would be a little bit different because
i'd be like okay this is this is your
home too so let's let's try and decide
together right but she was just staying
with me for a few weeks okay she wasn't
moving in okay and i was like
you're trying to this is trying to try
to move herself yeah yeah
um can i leave my toiletries here
no
and she was like oh please i was like no
she was like i just don't want you to
she's like oh i'll cry i was like you
can grow up
that's cool that's cool
i mean i had a russian guilt
i had a russian girlfriend and
literally from the second or third day
when i took her well it wasn't even um
the first date we went around her place
and it was all good but the second date
the first date sorry she went we walked
to my car to drive to the to the bar
that we were going to go to and she
started critiquing my car because it was
a two-seater convertible and she was
like this car's too small i need a
bigger car i was like this is the first
date then by the third date when we were
around my place she started critiquing
the decor
of my place i'm like this is the third
date at least give it a month before you
start changing my life
i wouldn't have got past the first day
you don't like it take an uber do you do
you think women try to change man
yeah yeah yeah
yeah constantly i think i think but it's
not always a bad thing that's that's
what i would yeah it's not always a
perfect some things are good some things
yeah yeah i think there's a there's a
general paradox i think
women try and change men and men expect
women to never change
i think you guys are more realistic
about what you have because of course
you'd want like a beyonce who is virgin
and and and holy and all that but you
can't get that in
real life so you just realistic okay
she's nice she's friendly she's pretty
and
that's what you go for so with women
they're not very
realistic about what they want
i think there was like this
um feminist lady she did like a survey
apparently like women had like 385
problems with the men that they dated
whereas men had only like 15 to 18
issues with the women that they dated on
average
that's hilarious yeah
so men are more already okay i'm not
gonna get beyonce i'm just gonna get
karen or whatever
oh they'll be fine with that well it's
interesting because there's so many
girls let's say like six feet six
figures six inches yeah but there's not
men that say that are average saying i
deserve a victorious secret yeah because
you're realistic yeah they well i think
reality hits men harder than women where
women whenever men have a standard
they're tried they're they're shamed for
it so like if they say i want thin
chicks they'll say fat shaming they'll
say i don't want to date a girl that's
been ran through it's slut-shaming
where women if we have a standard were
praised for it
yeah the thing is don't settle yeah
men
do have their standards i hear a lot in
the mgtow communities they're they're
constantly going about oh this woman is
this and i'm like dude have you looked
in the mirror have you seen who you are
yeah there's that one you start talking
about all these
terrible women out there so sometimes
men do have their unex and sort of
outrageous
expectations um and i've seen that
especially as i said these mgtow types
who who or even the incels who think
that you know these women are just
terrible i'm like dude
you have to fix yourself and then you'll
be amazed how much can i be honest
i think i think especially like maybe
intel's and stuff i think the reason
they're criticizing is because they feel
that they've been criticized a lot and
they feel like they don't measure up so
because it's the same thing like the
same insta model that they're
criticizing if she knocked in their door
you know he's taking her in a heartbeat
second you know i mean so i think i
don't think it comes from be necessary
because they think they deserve that i
think it's more because
because they've given up on the dating
game they feel that you know if they're
five
five and they don't meet six foot or six
figures all this and because we hear
that a lot that criticism from
women a lot i think they're like okay
well if i'm you're if i'm not you're
gonna criticize me for not being perfect
i'm gonna criticize you for not being
perfect well i think well i think a lot
of the problem too is like average women
are rejecting average men
and so it leaves men average men
frustrated because basically they'll let
the like a guy that's an eight nine or
ten will sleep with a four five or six
and so then that girl will think she's
on his level and then the average guy
has to deal with all the baggage at 30.
and so i think that's why they're
frustrated as they're like i'm sick of
the ran through 32 year olds yeah 33.
and now that that would have rejected me
at 22 but now they want me because all
the they call them chads right
all the chads like
rejected them so i understand where
they're coming from but
yeah i mean you know
there's it goes both ways i think the
way you refer to the opposite gender
kind of says more about you like if
you're the one saying men or trash men
are trash it says more about you same
thing with guys that say women are
[ __ ] women or horrors it's like the
same yeah but it is true that there is
this this this phenomena of women in
their 20s they ride what they call the
carousel there's another term to that as
well but they basically go through all
the different guys in their 20s and then
when they hit the wall in their mid-30s
or early 30s they look for the
the two main groups that in the in the
pickup artistry sort of game what they
call the the the lover and the and the
provider
now i myself have always been in the
provider category because i've never had
like you know good looking features in
in that sense so i've always known where
i can which pond i can fish in
but there's the you know the women go
through all the lovers all the
good-looking guys all the bad boys all
of that through their 20s and all the
providers are actually busy with their
head down in programming or
getting a job or doing whatever
and then suddenly in their 30s these
guys when they've reached a good level
of income and housing and and sort of
well to do those same girls in the 20s
who wouldn't give them the time of day
are knocking on their door
and back in the day there were a lot of
men who would simp for that and they
were like okay fine i'll take you even
though they know she's been ran through
the whole neighborhood
but this day day and age through the
internet and through a lot of people
like him in samuels
and actually pearl you could say she
could be one of those influences
they are now changing the game because a
lot of young men are now i mean i think
you've got the stats on how many of them
are virgin they don't actually they're
not engaging in the dating game anymore
because they're like why should i build
all this up make all this money do all
this hard work
just to throw it at the feet of some
some hooters girl who's who ran through
all the guys in the neighborhood in
their 20s and now she's knocking on my
door so i'm curious for the girls do you
know what the wall is
oh you do yeah okay it's a very a red
pill can you google um ish rolo tomasi
um the wall um
just in relation to um the stat you were
looking for yeah it's 70 so if people
earn over 70 thousands five percent okay
so five percent
okay nationwide
that makes sense nationwide yeah